bonjour christian joly
bonjour merci beaucoup d'être avec nous
ce matin sur rtl france alors c'est un
coup dur pour pour le monde de la nuit
et pour l'événementiel est ce qu'il ya
eu des des discussions avec avec votre
ministre de tutelle avait voulu des
garanties
des garanties c'est peu dire on a eu un
certain nombre de mesures qui ont été
décidées mais ce sont des mesures
connues qui évidemment vont nous
permettre de passer cette période de
crise n'est pas du tout au niveau que
nous aurions souhaité je rappelle que
les discothèques en fin d'année voit à
peu près par le mois de décembre
représente un peu plus de 20% de leur
chiffre d'affaires annuel donc j'ai bien
évident que les deux mesures
essentielles annoncé hier dans le
gouvernement sont très largement
insuffisant je pense au chômage partiel
bien sûr pour les salariés de notre
secteur d'activité qui va leur permettre
d'être couverts à 100 % ça c'est une
bonne mesure en revanche le dispositif
dit coûts fixes c'est à dire qui permet
de payer l'ensemble de nos charges va
être applicable mais c'est un dispositif
connus qui ne nous permet pas
malheureusement d'être indemnisé sur la
perte colossale du chiffre d'affaires
que nous allons enregistrer suite à
cette décision de fermeture alors les
bars les restaurants eux vont rester
fermés est ce que vous allez sauver le
sentiment que vous êtes vous retrouvé à
rouiller pardonnez moi est-ce que vous
avez le sentiment d'être les seuls
finalement à subir cette crise sanitaire
oui c'est la deuxième fois consécutive
que voulez-vous ya un paradoxe dans
cette décision
moi j'ai du mal à comprendre la position
du gouvernement savait qu'avec emmanuel
macron nous avons inauguré le pass
sanitaires il se trouve que quand il
nous a reçu le 21 juin dernier pour
décider de la réouverture des
discothèques nous avons échangé avec lui
et notamment mois particulièrement sur
le la mise en oeuvre de ce pass
sanitaire qui a été accompagnée d'un
contrôle d'identité qui donc était
appliquée uniquement aux discothèques de
france aucun je dis bien aucun secteur
d'activité n'a été aussi sécurisé que
les discothèques donc les discothèques
sont devenus des lieux très sécurisé
d'un point de vue sanitaire
et le paradoxe c'est qu'on va fermer ces
lieux là alors que depuis cinq mois que
nous sommes réouvert nous n'avons jamais
vu apparaître un seul cluster jamais
donc j'affirme que les discothèques sont
aujourd'hui le lieu le plus sécurisé
possible d'un point de vue sanitaire
malheureusement on va donc laisser la
clientèle qui fréquente est le lieu se
diriger vers d'autres lieux que vous
avez raison on restait ouvert mais
n'auront pas ses obligations ce qui veut
dire que le gouvernement par sa décision
va encourager la fraude au faux-pas
sanitaires et croyez moi je les constate
et à de multiples reprises les
tentatives de fraude sont nombreuses
donc nous on avait un outil pour les
déjouer c'était le contrôle de bulgari
et oui je ne comprends pas que le le
gouvernement ne puisse pas généraliser
ce dispositif qui a démontré son
efficacité
franchement là il ya une incohérence
totale pourrait amplifier leur innocence
l'incohérence et que dans les
restaurants on puisse aussi faire la
fête le 31 décembre prochain même si on
si on ne dîne autre incohérence et que
les jeunes finalement vont faire des
fêtes chez eux bien évident ont vengé le
regroupement des jeunes dans des lieux
clos où évidemment le port du masque que
les gestes barrière la suralcoolisation
sera évidemment évidente encore c'est
dommage parce que ça me rappelle l'année
2001 le sentiment que j'ai si vous
voulez et c'est ça qui m'inquiète le
plus c'est qu'on nous annonce quatre
semaines de fermeture moi je vais vous
dire ce qui va se passer qui va se
passer ça va être à peu près de même
nature qu'en 2020 nous pensions ré
ouvrira l'été et on nous a indiqué à
l'automne avait coûté messieurs comme
les autres n'ont pas été suffisamment
comment dire imprégné de la rigueur
nécessaire pour ne pas avoir une recrue
de la pandémie eh bien on va vous
laisser fermer un peu plus longtemps
donc voilà on va on va être victime une
nouvelle fois vous le verrez de la
double peine on nous dira après les
fêtes comme les gestes barrière n'ont
pas été respectées dans les autres lieux
où justement la rigueur n'était pas là
et bien les discothèques sera de nouveau
fermée pour une période beaucoup plus
longue que celle qui est annoncée
aujourd'hui c'est ça ma crainte
et un changement d'avis du gouvernement
vous pensez que c'est possible
aujourd'hui c'est compliqué je l'espère
évidemment nous on cherche à convaincre
ses menées c'est que c'est on a mis les
sodas santé qu'à une partie une
particularité il refuse de rencontrer
toutes les professions qui le
sollicitent nous avons été probablement
la seule profession à l'arrêt pendant 16
jours et nous la crise qu vide je crois
qu'on peut dire que malheureusement on
la connaît fort bien on sait ce qu'elle
a détruit dans notre dans notre
environnement direct 25 % de la
profession doit plus être ré ouvrir donc
vous savez pendant 16 mois de fermeture
on l'a sollicité le ministre de la santé
jamais jamais il a accepté de rencontrer
donc voilà c'est compliqué de discuter
avec quelqu'un qui malheureusement
refuse de me rencontrer et une autre
donnée on vient d'apprendre que le
variant omicron ne serait pas si
virulent que que cela en tout cas
transmissibles m'aimait pas mais pas
dangereux plus dangereux en tout cas que
les précédents virus çà çà çà çà vous
ouvre à une porte une lueur d'espoir
souhaitons-leur moi je vois que dans
toutes ces annonces eu le sentiment que
j'ai c'est que le gouvernement fait de
la politique vous me direz c'est son
rôle sauf que il livre à l'opinion
publique la fermeture des discothèques
vous voyez j'ai fait quelque chose sauf
que la décision qu'il a prise ne
correspondent absolument à rien je me
rappelle les lieux qui sont les nôtres
sont les plus sécurisés des milliers de
jeunes se sont croisés depuis le 9
juillet des milliers nous n'avons pas eu
une seule contamination nous n'avons pas
détecté à seul kloster et renferment ces
établissements là voilà ce qui me met en
colère voilà ce qui me conduit à dire
que cette décision-là est complètement
incohérente merci beaucoup christian
juni d'avoir accepté notre invitation ce
matin sur rtl france je le rappelle vous
êtes délégué général du syndicat
national des discothèques